Infowars host and sweaty freedom fighter
Alex Jones knows that telling the truth
gets you sued a lot that's why he and
his alt media a-team are facing numerous
defamation lawsuits as defendants which
is legal jargon for victims but Alex and
his Infowars crew know it's reporting
and not defamation when he encourages
his audience to speculate that mass
shootings are stage and the people
affected are really crisis actors what
is your tank on on Sandy Hook all the
people that look and act like actors you
look at the Aurora shooting that was
totally staged the reason why the same
people keep appearing on TV is because
they are the ones being trained and they
may actually even have some experience
in you know acting is that David Hogg
being told what to say
struggling to get out his lines to clear
his good name Alex is holding a press
conference in DC where he'll explain why
he's really the one being slandered and
as a like-minded citizen journalist
I'm sure he'll welcome me to the event
with open arms I made it ten feet in I'm
just trying to go to the Alex Jones
event no they just told you to leave the
Press Club Alex Jones believes in a free
independent media just doesn't sound
like him
he wouldn't do that I mean it's almost
like it's not him oh my god
oh my god oh my god and that's when I
realized what the actual Alex Jones
would think false flag false flag false
flag watching the livestream of the
press conference I'm absolutely certain
that there is a decent possibility that
this is a crisis actor playing Alex
Jones
[Music]
it sounds like Alex but something's just
not right I mean he's hardly sweating at
all that so scary about this is maybe
that's an authentic brow white but the
real Alex Jones would want me to
confront this impostor with or without
proof
hey I gotta ask you so I wasn't actually
able to get into the Savannah Miss
citizen journalist it made me concerned
that you weren't the real Alex Jones
that you were yourself a crisis actor
again I just want to be clear I'm not
calling you a crisis actor
I think you're the victim of these
lawsuits and obviously calling a victim
a crisis actor would be a monster
you guys said I said that edited the
tape and then sat there and said what a
piece of crap to try to get anger in
your target viewers so let me get this
straight the person standing in front of
me is saying that you have never ever
cyborg you've never implied that the
victims of any mass shooting were fakes
no that's not the truth when you're
saying things that might impact real
people's lives do you feel any sense of
responsibility actually I've seen of the
question do you feel any sense of
responsibility well I don't feel
responsibility for you guys
misrepresenting what I've said to then
try to ban free speech free speech gives
me the right to be able to chain people
no no sorry okay well done oh that's
been found in court if you're the real
Alex Jones why haven't you offered to
sell me any supplement yet I know I'm
not like FB Zoe's sits there and he's
the biggest supplement seller in the
world but I'm not allowed to sell
supplements that's right Jeff Bezos you
take it acetylide no this break and all
it's true Whole Foods can sell
supplements but I can
good point you sound scripted sir sure
you sounds know that response is real
supplements are a fifty billion dollar
industry if it's real how do I know it
there you go
eat your brain for forcing supplements
on people whether they want them or not
feels like the real Alex oh wow mmm they
taste like huckster wait could that have
been him
and he didn't even drop the sales pitch
I wonder what this lingering superfan
thinks the man that I encountered on the
street you think that was the real Alex
Jones because I accused that man of
being a crisis actor yeah you were he's
the most real person in the media today
I'll vouch for you that's the real
answer reel out shows only a monster
would take a man going through a really
hard time and accuse him of lying and
being an actor what kind of Turkey piece
of mi and anyone who would do that
thank God I'm the only example of this I
can think of thankfully alex is having
another event across town maybe he could
find it in his heart to forgive me I
just want to apologize to you I think
it's what any decent person lives don't
you think that me apologizing to you is
the right thing I think that you chucky
cheese the rent chucky cheese the wrap
and ask the hotel have the rat remove
decent thing for a person to do in a
situation like that is apologize the
only decent thing for a person like me
to do is apologize to the victims
they'd slander that's all I'm saying
you're laying your hands on me I'm going
I'm clearly walking it's too late to say
sorry going forward I'll think more
clearly at least he didn't dump out all
those delicious pills
it must be a bad batch